let's try instead our caller from the
six one nine area code caller from six
one nine go ahead hey how you doing good
this is my first time actually uh
watching your show and I took a look at
your videos before I solve this is this
video for this show and I was like I
really liked like the message in the
perspective thank you don't just do that
on another media source so thank you for
doing what you're doing I think
alternatives and thought new sources are
awesome appreciate cybermat so my
question is more along lines of
perspective actually the last caller was
gave a really great I you know
perspectives and it's interesting how
people see things from their point of
view when I did that awesome
the issue is is I think it's mean
exploited and unfortunately and I'll
give an example with it what I mean by
this and it's being exploited by the
Trump administration and by the media
and my question is more along the lines
of what what can we do about I mean
guess with the vote yes we can write a
congressman yes we can write our senator
but to give an example I live I'm a
disabled veteran who lives down here in
Tijuana Mexico looking at Los Cerritos
and I had front-row seats to what was
happening right here at the border at
the San Ysidro border I spoke to the
Honduran people and the migrants down
here I spoke to the Mexican people I
have friends and family who who who live
down here and what I saw and what I was
seeing lies in front of my eyes on my
own two eyes and getting the perspective
was not at all what you saw on any of
the media sites and including which
we're reading from people who are given
their perspective and of course the
Trump administration contradicts itself
every term which is not new information
okay so hold on IV see if I can just is
this interesting but I want to see if we
can focus it in a way that might be more
relevant to the audience tell us what
you were seeing and what ways what you
were seeing not what what is being
portrayed in the media well that for one
thing when I was down here at the border
and I was looking at and I was talking
to the migrants the methodology which
was a skewed that
this is not a an invading force invading
forests with a literate that they were
you know strategizing something what
they were looking for in their own mind
what if I just get across the border if
I just can get over there even if they
have a gun in my face
I can I can I can claim asylum because I
these are you can hear the desperation
in their voice so when they were going
there at no point did they think I'm not
gonna get a shot they're not gonna hit
me with anything you know they may stop
me but block me but all I need to do is
get one toe over there and say hey
please help me and I'll get help
so when the tear gas showed up and when
the rubber bullets were happening there
was an honest feeling of shock but when
you go on the news media and when you
you get a totally different point of
view of oh they were attacking it there
was no attacking
none they were standing there and when
you see that with drones widening your
like I lived here I see it and then you
hear everyone else saying no no that's
not what's really happening what's
really happening is this because either
Trump said it or you know I I heard it
on this blog or some some podcast I'm
like I was there I how I guess how do
you as a citizen be able to take
perspective and in but also be able to
say this is what reality looks like
because that person is in that reality
that person is there yeah well listen I
mean to some degree you can't show up
personally at the site of every news
story so to some degree we do have to
rely on what media and our politicians
tell us the fact that we can and that we
are given so much misinformation is
hugely problematic and that gets that's
a much higher level issue that goes
beyond just immigration and the border
that comes to media activism that comes
to supporting media outlets that you
believe are actually doing good work and
that and this comes to electing people
that you think are more likely to tell
you the truth so this is a much bigger
issue because it's not I mean I don't
know what you think the the the solution
would be but it's not practical to
imagine that every person is just going
to physically go to the location of
every news story we do have to have some
proxy to know
what the world is right mm-hmm and
furthermore we have to have a compromise
on what reality looks like and I think a
lot of it stems from it starts with one
little misconception or misleading
thought and then from there the division
happens and I think what's been
happening in politics is that they've
been capitalizing on that minor
misconception and instead of correcting
that course they just widen it and now I
talked to former friends of mine and
they're still friends I don't want to
clear friends and family of mine but
they don't talk to me anymore because
I'm just you know I'm my point of view
so askew and I'm like and I try to bring
them back to Center and say listen this
is what reality looks like can we agree
on that and I can't yeah yeah right now
we have a fundamental situation or the
current administration is just straight
up saying that the facts are not the
facts and that's that's like a bigger
systemic problem listen I got 25 people
holding so I'm gonna let you go I
appreciate the call and yeah IFIF we
can't even agree on the most basic facts
then it's really but we're really we're
really in trouble